pour maman de septembre noir en jordanie
il se trouve que j'arrive en jordanie on
est dans un hôtel avec la presse
internationale
quand éclate le conflit entre les
besoins enfin le roi le roi du chêne de
jordanie et les palestiniens
bon il se trouve qu'un filet un commando
palestinien arrive dans l'hôtel et bouc
zottel est quasiment font prisonniers
les journalistes
le hasard fait que une demi-heure avant
j'étais sorti j'avais un rendez vous
donc j'étais sorti je sors jeu et je me
retrouve en pleine bataille au milieu de
la bataille je suis le seul formidable
je veux dire rendez compte quelle
expérience cette guerre entre les
palestiniens et michel d'ornano
je suis le seul trait ou sans travaux
curl maintenant quelle est la vérité
quand vous êtes au coeur d'une bataille
vous vous cachez derrière des murs et
vous regarder des gens cachés derrière
des murs qui tire sur des gens cachés
derrière des murs comprenez rien mais
rien c'est dangereux vous couchez vous
mâche un mec qui tire sur qui pour quoi
et ça vous ne comprenez rien c'est
vraiment fabbro fabrice à waterloo mais
x par mille
rien donc très bien je peux raconter
tout ce qui s'est passé mais je
comprenais rien je ne savais pas qu'ils
avaient gagné en vérité est là dessus je
reviens à l'hôtel et là je vois tous les
journalistes qui eux n'avaient rien vu
puisqu'il avait été bloquée dans l'hôtel
mais il avait écouté toutes les radios
radio israel radio jordanie radio le
quai et ceux qui m'ont expliqué il
n'avait rien eu mais ils m'ont expliqué
le sens ce que j'avais vu à ce que moi
je n'avais rien compris
ben voilà très souvent c'est ça la
réalité
[Musique]